Laura it's so good to see you and I know
you stepped off an airplane and just
barely made it here on time in it but
thanks to you guys there were golf carts
and beautiful it's beyond I'm so lucky
to be here to honor
Timmy sha'lame and to be with you all
cuz I love this or it's so much I love
the way he paid tribute to you and told
you on stage in front of everybody what
an inspiration you have been in his life
an acting career that's very beautiful
and we've just had an amazing experience
working together on this film Little
Women so we just finished right before
Christmas so and he said you could just
spend Halloween together told me your
daughter is here tonight are you now
gonna write him into big little lies
maybe I mean I think we'd be very lucky
to have him very very amazing but Meryl
Streep who was also in Little Women is
in big little lies so she and I got to
do two things in a row which was a dream
Laura things have been going so
incredibly well how old is your daughter
now she's 14 oh my gosh yes she was I
remember that so life is going is it
going at too hectic a pace now between
doing the TV shows shooting films I feel
blessed so blessed I'm the daughter of
actors so I know that that you feel
privileged and blessed when you're doing
what you love and the world's a crazy
place so I think getting to make art is
a very luxurious opportunity and isn't
it wonderful being the first presenter
up there tonight because you can chill
out oh yeah I'm going to go sit down and
watch my friends get celebrated it's an
amazing night well happy new year oh by
the way the film festival is 30 years
old do you remember how you celebrated
your 30th birthday
I might have been in Palm Springs and
I'm not even making that up because my
mother lived here part time I think we
may have done it in Palm Springs and had
a big dinner party
Oh believe it or not you know what I am
really glad I am I know that's a pretty
amazing thing at rocketclub speaking of
the Oscars whoo since we do not have a
host yet any ideas I have no words to
share this moment only because having
done a Star Wars film and you learn to
say nothing in interviews so I because
I'm a governor of the Academy I'm not
supposed to write share yet but I think
we're all trying to figure that out you
are so responsible okay mom
[Music]